hey listen guys
I saw dots amp on TikTok
before and tig TikTok movies that enoplan with 37 seats
the largest is in the Netherlands
after that I saw cornflakes on TikTok
that one sheet with 150 seats
has become the largest in the Netherlands
of course we partied 2 days in a row
danced with champagne
oysters lobster
and the whole mikmak
and that coxian of angel plan the new minister
going to be president
now it comes
can't be true
so today I saw on the news
that it is not correct at all
NL plan has 0 0
seat
what 1 rock region
at first I got very angry
and I wanted to block all tickers
but then I thought
hey and that plan
you can't do that
because we you and I always have a team together
worked hard and hard
day in day out
but fair is fair
NL plan did not get a seat
we have to be honest with yourself
we just have
given everything and done our best
determined and full of courage
it does not matter
don't give up better next time
next time we will work even harder
yes that is 1 good plan